ne remarquant jamais que la tension est le seul fruit de nos limitations.
Nous n'avons pas échappé à la douleur.
Nos blessures de guerre ne sont pas que légères.
Et pourtant, malgré notre désir et notre volonté de guérir,
nous nous trouvons souvent à lutter dans la mêlée,
nous accrochant à des représentations erronées
de tout ce que nous ne sommes pas.
Alors que nos rêves sont en adéquation, nos peurs entrent en collision.
Nous voulons connaître l'autre mais pensons ne pas pouvoir.
Le gouffre entre l'empathie et l'équité
est aussi insondable que les fissures qui tapissent notre intégrité collective.
Nous passons des éternités éternelles
à essayer d'en faire une vertu.
Peut-être avez-vous rencontré un ou deux vertueux en chemin.
Il n'y en a que très peu
et je sais que j'ai, de temps en temps,
cru que des imposteurs étaient réels,
mais je fais de la place à l'éventualité que ce soit moi l'imposteur.
S'il vous plaît, accrochez-vous, je guéris
mais je ne plie plus sous la volonté de mes blessures
ni de ceux qui m'ont blessée.
Je préfère ouvrir mes bras comme Nüt jusqu'à devenir le ciel.
Je préfère étirer ma langue sous la vérité,
notre pont à traverser quand nous regardons dans les yeux.
Mais la langue, comme le cœur, se fatigue.
Le faible rend le fait de rester inspiré difficile pour le fort,
comme le perdu empêche le trouvé de s'échapper du bourbier
et le dégénéré empêche l'éclairé de nous amener plus haut.
Peu importe ce que vous entendez de la bouche de ces menteurs,
nous sommes un seul peuple
avec un destin et un ennemi commun,
c'est pourquoi cela me tourmente de voir nos cœurs déchirés,
nos esprits éparpillés,
nos égos si facilement flattés.
Nous sommes asservis mais voyons nos entraves comme des cadeaux.
Au lieu de résister à nos maîtres, nous les laissons agrandir nos fossés,
tels de stupides accros au matériel,
nous cherchons ce qui nous abaisse, pas ce qui nous élève.
Mais quelque part en nous,
il y a eu un changement de paradigme.
La justice enchaînée s'agite.
Notre jeunesse trouve inutile de séparer son âme de son cerveau,
sa vérité est ancrée, son intégrité n'est pas alimentée.
Laissez-moi attirer votre attention sur ceux qui servent d'exemple.
Ceux qui, au quotidien, donnent tout
mais leurs réserves sont toujours abondantes.
Ceux qui luttent contre amis et ennemis,
mais dont l'espoir n'est pas bafoué,
ils font de la musique, pas des samples,
et la laideur du monde ne pourrait jamais révoquer
la plénitude et la douceur de leur composition.
Ni la pure vérité de leur mission.
Il est temps que nous nous taisions et écoutions.
Que nous fermions les yeux et priions
pour l'humilité et les conseils
afin de les suivre sur la voie.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
(Cris)
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
(Cris)
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Merci beaucoup à vous tous,
vous ne savez pas à quel point cela est gratifiant et stimulant.
Ces trois dernières années,
j'ai eu le privilège de participer avec mes voisins à la conception
d'un espace à la Nouvelle-Orléans appelé « Sous les Ponts ».
En 1966, l'autoroute 10 est arrivée dans le quartier Tremé,
délogeant 326 magasins détenus par des personnes noires,
plus de 300 chênes,
détruisant le district commercial noir le plus fructueux de la région,
perturbant la richesse intergénérationnelle
et démantelant les fondations
du plus vieux quartier afro-américain de la nation.
Aujourd'hui, après 45 ans de défense de la communauté,
après 500 heures d'engagement communautaire
et 80 heures de conception communautaire,
nous sommes ravis qu'en 2018,
après avoir entendu les voix de milliers de résidents
et reçu le soutien de nos partenaires locaux, fédéraux et philanthropiques,
alors que la ville célèbre ses 300 ans à transformer le monde,
nous transformerons 19 pâtés de maisons sous l'autoroute en espace communautaire,
en magasins détenus par des noirs,
sous la forme du couloir Clairbone d'innovation culturelle du district.
(Cris)
(Applaudissements)
Nous créerons une passerelle dans le temps, dans la mémoire,
nous remédierons aux disparités et à l'injustice
et nous avons hâte de vous voir de l'autre côté.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)